es war absolut elektrisierend auch etwas
beängstigend was ihre maske am frühen
samstagmorgen europäischer zeit
präsentierte ein mini computer interface
und er konnte zeigen dass und wie es
funktioniert es ist absolut irre
er will krankheiten damit therapien aber
auch künstliche intelligenz durch
menschen kontrollierbar machen
die zukunft hat begonnen computer und
menschen verschmelzen und musk konnte
schon ergebnisse zeigen und die waren
absolut mein blick zum science im future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's herzlich willkommen
pixum science fiction gibt's jetzt auch
übrigens fürs fahrradfahren für die u
bahn auto und so weiter als podcast für
unterwegs der link ist hier unter me und
in der video beschreibung mehr als eine
halbe stunde verspätung in annas
spannenden die welt wirklich auf die
folter und viele kommentare im
livestream vermuteten schon dass
irgendetwas schief gegangen sei aber
dann ging es doch los und die
vorstellung raubte einem quasi den atem
denn was maske da vorstellte war
tatsächlich eine smarte birnen device
ein computer brain interface das kaum
größer als eine münze ist und so dick
wie die schädeldecke denn da soll es
hinein transplantiert werden und um die
sensation perfekt zu machen innerhalb
von einer stunde von einem
spezialisierten roboter es wird ein münz
großes loch in die schädeldecke gefräst
und dann kommt darin die device
patientinnen und patienten brauchen
keine vollnarkose und können noch am
selben tag wieder nach hause dann aber
angeschlossen an einen computer über
bluetooth geladen wird link 0.9 frau so
heißt die device über induktion also
über nacht wie bei der apple watch viele
maske vision regelrechtes brain hecking
und was er am samstagmorgen zeigt das
ließ einen erschaudern im sommer 2016
gründete erneuerer link mit acht
weiteren personen das ziel nervenzell
bereiche aktivieren und ihre signale
interpretieren und das im großen stil
für die masse eben eine art hirn cloud
also in der die gehirne der menschen
vernetzt werden alle gedanken wären dann
für jeden der an diese hirn cloud
angeschlossen ist
verfügbar im märz 2017 hat mass das
erste mal in der öffentlichkeit über die
pläne von eurer link gesprochen demnach
soll es nur noch wenige jahre dauern bis
die entwickelte technologie so weit ist
dass sie bereits bei menschen mit
schweren hirnschäden eingesetzt werden
kann patienten und patientinnen mit
gedächtnisproblemen oder einem
hirnschlag könnten so ihr gehirn wieder
effektiver nutzen und im livestream
zählte er noch weitere
behandlungsmöglichkeiten auf taubheit
blindheit depressionen extreme schmerzen
ängste lähmung schlaflosigkeit
epileptische anfälle suchterkrankungen
die technologie könnte also tatsächlich
schon in ein paar jahren effektiv und
innerhalb eines tages menschen von den
symptomen schlimmer krankheiten befreien
aber ist das nur ein einfallstor ein
trojanisches pferd für etwas ganz
anderes für etwas größeres denn
langfristig sind es nicht die kranken
menschen auf die maske es mit seinem
unternehmen neuerer link abgesehen hat
es soll vor allem eine apokalypse der ki
der künstlichen intelligenz vermieden
werden vor der maske in der nahen
zukunft waren erinnert immer wieder
daran dass im laufe der evolution immer
wieder mal die weniger intelligente
spezies durch die intelligente verdrängt
worden ist nur wenn der mensch mit
maschinen verschmilzt und dadurch klüger
schneller und produktiver wird werden
wir musk vorstellungen zufolge nicht von
der ki abgehängt und für mäurer link hat
maske eine menge hochkarätiger experten
und expertinnen am start angefangen weil
sich selbst oft auch als der da vinci
unserer zeit bezeichnet wohl
unbestritten einer der besten ingenieure
weltweit dazu kommt der ehemalige chef
chip designer von ibm und noch weitere
erfolgreiche erfinder und erfinderinnen
nicht zu vergessen auch einige der
besten neurochirurgen weltweit natürlich
ist das menschliche gehirn super komplex
doch im grunde funktioniert es ähnlich
wie ein computer nämlich mit hilfe von
einsen und nullen also den binärcode
eine eins steht für die aktion einer
nervenzelle die null steht für den
ruhezustand dort der größte unterschied
so computern nervenzellen verändern sich
permanent sie ordnen sich für kurze oder
lange zeit an
so können wir uns immer mehr wissen
einprägen es aber auch wieder vergessen
oder verändern
durch das so genannte machine learning
kann auch ein computer dazu laden aber
wenn er dinge einmal kann oder weiß gibt
es keine möglichkeit dieses abzustufen
oder abzuschwächen
diese lücke will maske mit neuling
schließen doch wie genau soll das
funktionieren bei der gestern
vorgestellten smart device link 0.9 v
implantiert der operation roboter kleine
elektrische fäden aus der device direkt
ins menschliche gehirn und zwar so
vorsichtig dass es nur zu minimalen
verletzungen kommt der roboter kann
vermeiden dass diese fäden in adern
stechen und es blutet musk zeigte
gestern wie diese fäden genauso
implantiert werden so dass sie nur im
hirngewebe landen so entsteht die
computerhirn schnittstelle mit 1024
kanälen es können mehrere interfaces
implantiert werden
so werden wir menschen in die lage
versetzt direkt mit unserem bewusstsein
im computer systeme zu gehen laut musk
werden k s in solch einem fall unsere
kollegen bzw
nachbarn erhofft sich dass wir sie so
verstehen und mit ihnen interagieren er
erhofft sich dass wir uns so unseren
lebensraum mit der ki teilen können und
sie uns nicht gefährlich wird falls dies
alles funktioniert würde es die welt wie
wir sie kennen komplett umkrempeln
anstand eine mail zu tippen würde es
ausreichen einfach kurz an den
gewünschten inhalt zu denken der
computer verwandelt unsere gedanken dann
in den entsprechenden text zudem hätten
wir zugriff auf die gedanken und
erfahrungen anderer menschen so könnten
wir also problemlos die erfahrung von
anderen erleben zum beispiel die eines
promis oder eines soldaten
auch wenn wir bestimmtes fachwissen
haben wollen müssen wir nur an diesem
wunschdenken und könnten schon die
gedanken entsprechende experten und
expertinnen herunterladen und das würde
alles verändern plötzlich würden wir an
gedanken rankommen über die wir noch
nicht mal heute zusammen sprechen und da
gibt es ja viele viele beispiele
rassismus wer so ein thema glaube und so
weiter und so fort die menschheit könnte
sich rasend schnell darüber austauschen
doch nicht nur die aktion zwischen
menschen und computern würde so komplett
verändert werden sondern außerdem auch
die kommunikation zwischen den menschen
untereinander
denn die kommunikation verliefen nach
mass plänen dann direkt zwischen gehirn
und gehört
ohne datenverlust oder verzögerung weder
unser mund noch unsere sprache wären
dann mehr notwendig um komplexe inhalte
an andere zu vermitteln wir könnten
abstrakte gedanken übertragen wir hätten
zum beispiel zugriff auf das gehirn von
ihnen maske und er witzelte gestern auch
da mit und stellten die vermutung auf
dass er vielleicht auch schon ein
implantat in sich trägt weil die
operation ebenso harmlos ist auch viele
missverständnisse die durch das bloße
hören von informationen entstehen würden
so von jetzt auf gleich beseitigt es
könnten viel mehr daten zwischen
menschen übertragen werden klingt alles
nach science-fiction pur
doch musk konnte absolut bahnbrechendes
gestern zeigen mörder link hat die neue
details in das gehirn eines schweins
implantiert auf dem laufband konnte die
technologie exakt vorhersagen wie das
schwein seine beine bewegen würde
durch das auslesen der entsprechenden
impulse die elektroden konnten die
signale so exakt auslesen dass das
möglich ist absolut irre oder hier
konnte man hören wie das gehirn feuert
und wie exakt diese signale ausgelesen
werden können
doch das ist erst der anfang wie mast
auf dem event verkündete war dieses
event eine recruiting event mass gesucht
also gezielt leute also er möchte leute
anstellen die programmieren oder chips
entwickeln können und nicht irgendwelche
leute seinen aufruf ging so wie ich es
verstanden habe an die besten leute von
apple oder google ohne dass es
allerdings ausgesprochen hat er sucht
nach leuten die schon mal dran beteiligt
waren eine die weiß auf den markt zu
bringen als software engineer oder bei
der chip entwicklung konkret nannte er
eine smart watch ein schelm der böses
dabei denkt und wenn man die größen
vergleicht dann ist links 0.9 genauso
groß wie die apple watch und hat sehr
ähnliche features nur stadt mit sensoren
wie die apple wort schließt link 0.9 v
die informationen direkt im gehirn aus
und auch die versionsnummer sagt eine
menge über das produkt es muss noch
weiterentwickelt werden zu 1 v und dafür
werden leute aus dem apple watch team
zum beispiel wahrscheinlich erste wahl
in maske warnt vor künstlicher
intelligenz anklicken anschauen und
abonnieren
in dem video geht es genau um dieses
thema was künstliche intelligenz für
katastrophale auswirkungen haben könnte
also diesen kanal abonnieren dieses
video anklicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran